It is here at the Invictus Games
that you realize
whatever you carry,
it was the springboard
that propelled you to the next level.
[cheering and applause]
[dramatic music playing]
[Harry] The Games doesn't focus
on what causes the injury,
but really about the recovery
and how to be part of a community again.
[man] When I was a soldier,
that meant the world to me.
Once I was wounded,
how do you define yourself then?
[in English]
I've been fighting a long time.
- [man 1] Drinking a lot, going out a lot.
- [man 2] I have flashbacks.
I would like to be the father
playing with his kids, playing football.
[in English] 90% of my team
are currently serving four to five--
[explosion]
There is a shelling.
[intense music playing]
- [crowd cheers]
- [whistle blows]
[Harry] If your goal
was to make your country proud,
you've done it.
How are we doing?
Everyone's gonna struggle at some point.
I've got demons saying,
"You're not gonna do this."
[Harry] If your goal
was to make your family happy,
you've achieved it.
My dad just scored there.
Clearly someone sees something in me.
[Harry] You are people of substance,
of resilience,
of strength.
You have the Heart of Invictus.
[crowd cheering]